oh my god we figured it out they're
meant to be we figured you out
Australian snacks a level one to ten I'd
say I'm probably like eight yeah I was
gonna say like a six seven I'm like a 9
maybe maybe I'm a nine also what's the
question I think I know this is I
thought it wasn't a tell abut now I know
that this is Benjamin I've never heard
anyone speak positively about this food
oh my god oh wow it's really salty which
I love
I imagine that eventually you stop
making this facial expression while
eating it so is this for when you're
sick or this just like just a normal
candy it's like a spa for your mouth
this is the best thing I've ever put in
my mouth what am i tasting there's a
relaxant it's like a palate cleanser
this is not a STONER yeah Tim Tams
these are also great a brand new
culinary experience for me also like
they melt in your hand I don't know one
yeah you're like the Girl Scout cookies
of Australia I'm super into these
whatever hype that you have heard I'm
sure this is living up to that I see
myself sitting down in me like I'm gonna
have one yeah they have the llama
[ __ ] monster
oh Jesus Jesus fingerless is fun okay I
approach easels okay geez off there
Mexico on your finger like that look at
that other I think I'm in love with
cheese look I move in with you so I
could see myself taking cheezles home to
meet my parents this is a good stoner
food you know I do tizi all right Milo
let's give it a try and hopefully we'll
be running like Sakura playing soccer
and it's like Nesquik kind of some
people you did dry I feel like I'll
forget how to swallow well you have this
right here yeah doesn't taste as bad as
it smells
Yeah right I think it's tricking me that
it's good for me my kid would look at
this and cry caramello koala koalas are
a big deal uh-huh they're vicious right
here look at this guy got hot I'm sad
that it's so cute because like there is
a little bit of me that is not enjoying
biting the heads off of things
oh this is like Easter candy it's like a
Hershey's chocolate bar it's like
caramel from like Twix these are really
sweet 10 out of 10 would munch on koalas
again twisties that's a cute name all
this [ __ ] tastes way more natural than
the food that we eat though I will say
that yeah absolutely I mean they're
really good but like a bugle better
razor oh we don't have no beautiful I
don't know if I see myself eating these
like in my parents basement
I got you twist these I'm on board with
this yes Astra you can't get still it's
illegal you guys are a country started
from criminals
I liked probably 75% 65% of them I think
this is Grace on her food tube job boys
this is dating profile picture and
here's what he looks like when you knew
he was real Oh